previously on TV sins must exist certain
words in a certain specific order that
would explain all of this but with her I
just I just can't ever seem to find them
you had me at hello
[Music]
Walking Dead episode opens with still
shots of nature in the sounds of wind
and crickets cliche and since the last
episode I sinned open up with a
helicopter I might as well add a Walking
Dead episode opens with a shot of a
helicopter cliche funny how when the
show doesn't need the walkers to be a
threat they just lumber in the
background but as soon as the show needs
the tension dialed up then get
unavoidable in ferocious this watch
indicates that time is moving very very
fast but I've watched this show enough
to know that unfortunately the opposite
is true
I know we've mentioned clothes before
but this episode has the audacity will
imply that somehow even the boxers
showing above my saggy jeans guy would
somehow still have his pants on is
Michonne hiking those up for him every
five minutes the Marvel zombie origin
story of Hawkeye's somehow makes it into
this episode also what are the chances
that in all these zombie apocalypse
scenarios there are this many people
left that are exceptional with a bow and
arrow
I mean conservatively what's the
percentage of people in the world that
are experts with a bow and arrow three
percent eight percent I'm not looking
that up but I'm guessing the chances of
coming up on random people that can hit
a zombie in the eye every time they draw
back is slim to none especially in
Atlanta now Janine I said reach for him
as if you hadn't had a body to eat for
days maybe even weeks this isn't the
half-assing dead last time I checked
what is he waiting for here you know
it's the guy's a zombie so why wouldn't
he just stab him already
does he know Andrea and Michonne are
watching him and he will have to explain
the no matter how you die you turned
into a zombie rule later because that's
honestly the only way the sequence makes
it he flat out murders a group of
military men who are very much alive
later in this episode without blinking
an eye seriously they're acting like
they still haven't noticed them they
certainly saw or heard Michonne Samurai
tweedle dead and tweedle dead or just
then so why wait oh it's a small world
after all it's a small world after all
it's a small convenient world I was
about a big hug for your old pal Marv
a full minute of Andrea floating in and
out of consciousness that's exactly the
kind of hardcore zombie action that has
made this show a can't-miss for years
well are we that's not for me to say why
not you can't just say this is Woodbury
or anything along those lines or more
creative ways to draw on suspense than
just having characters be dodgey with
pronoun games and refusing to answer
simple questions she was wondering if I
was real
hoping I was really don't care either
way Bayley remember Merle considering
it's been at least 15 years since he's
been on the show right
wait this is only season 3 are we sure
that story line on the farm didn't last
for five seasons cuz I'm pretty sure it
did
ain't so many of us left sure they're
right but how do they know this the West
Coast very well could have competent
people that knew how to deal with zombie
outbreaks I can't say this enough this
thing shouldn't have lasted a week he
wanted to keep looking and things happen
people died interesting because things
happen people died is exactly the
detailed summary for every single
episode of this show a lot of them Kim
Dale I've already had to suffer through
these events andrea is describing and
what seemed like real time so to listen
to her repeat all this nonsense is
giving me post barn stress disorder PTSD
is a thing right sad to say but I kind
of signed with my name is Merle here he
had no clue who they were or why they
were spying on his men and Michonne had
a [ __ ] sword
however we died we all turned my easy
nose to swallow at first but there it is
well I feel like I've heard this 37
times since Rick first brought it up in
the previous season finale swallowed it
many times over I'm ready to start
spitting instead welcome to Woodbury
another in a series of locations our
heroes can find a home in until it
becomes obvious something of furious is
going on and then have to fight to
escape and be on the run again because
this show is nothing if not predictable
but I'm sure that won't happen here come
with me
close enough roll commercials the other
side of town there is the streets
they're all Gardens like this why is it
really that crazy to think that you
could barricade a city from
unintelligent meandering to heavy lambs
to the slaughter
this not only seems possible but lately
some nicknames stick whether you wanted
to or not Andrea would be dead to rights
at TV sets and leave them to rot great
to know
makes people uneasy considering the
amount of dead that are already
apparently all around wouldn't the
entire planet just smell like rotting
meat right now I'd think it'd be like
how pet owners just get used to the
smell of the pets except in this case
the pets are piles of sentient rotting
flesh it means that's a pop so our kid
will make it 74 can we stop saying
pregnant women or about to pop air
balloons
god damn baby making bad asses sorry
your patrols do on the way in last night
they had a dead one strung up like an
ornament why does it even matter
Michonne dragged two dead ones around
with her for protection your crew has
used the walkers for all sorts of your
own purposes why would this indicate any
kind of problem at all 22 seconds of the
walking governor also this gardener is
raking the only pile of debris in the
entire yard
to the same pile it's already in it's
like a toddler pretending to eat by
pushing the food around the plate we're
on to you buddy now eat your piece you
know your brother down she did then talk
to her again
see what else you can find out even
though we all know the governor is an
evil [ __ ] the show wants to attempt
to draw out some suspense with that
reveal but since Milton and Merle both
know his true colors the governor
playing nice here with them really
doesn't make any sense take away their
ability to eat they lose interest in
doing so they lose interest they lose
interest since when the walkers have
thoughts about what they're interested
in but failed to follow through on them
because of minor obstacles these are
zombies not millenials why keep them but
how exactly does this work
zombies can't see them because of other
zombies doesn't that mean if you're in a
group of more than three zombies you're
automatically invisible is this why no
one notices me at parties and they're
not eating why don't they starve they
are starving they just do it slower than
we do oh it was like we're trying to
impose logic on the cash cinema suits
what's your secret really big walls
let's soldier had walls too and we all
know how that turned out
how would Andrea know this she wasn't in
the room with the governor earlier when
he found out and he doesn't strike me as
the type to share any information he
doesn't have to well they found him we
sure did we found you too
there are so many ways this ambush
doesn't make sense first why would you
put yourself in harm's way like this
when you clearly have them surrounded
and ambushed anyway the only thing
you're accomplishing here is making them
aware of your presence and giving away
the element of surprise just to try to
earn it back second because the rest of
your crew is ambushing from the treeline
behind them you might as well call Clint
Eastwood because you're directly in the
line of fire third you're telling me
that none of these dozen or so well
armed persons from the ambush unit we're
paying enough attention to squeeze off a
direct shot at you as soon as you pulled
that gun chair they were happy about
their friend but it would only take a
split-second of reaction to snap out of
that and finally you're saying that your
guys took this entire group out with
immediate kill shots from that far away
are they terminators I feel like there
must be terminators let's see what owns
the Sam brought us shall we or at least
what's left of it after we needlessly
shot it all to pieces and an
ill-conceived ambush that was really
more of an attempt to throw an obvious
twist at the audience instead of being
remotely logical must go faster now
swing away your brother Darren my
brother Darryl that's my other brother
Darryl even though he's clinging to life
he told us about his convoy on the
highway his man mankind that word should
have new meaning for all of us today
welcome to the head Museum I'm Leonard
Nimoy